dumb money is the incredible true story
about how your average day-to-day person
made life-changing money at the expense
of the one percent the movie was shot in
a way that most people in Hollywood
can't comprehend kovid actually sped up
the production process and the amount of
truth behind every scene will shake you
to your core one unique thing that the
cast experienced while filming this
movie was the way it was shot most of
the actors hadn't experienced a shoot
where they were pretty much the only
actor on set for a week it's so fast and
seamless that it kind of you know it
even fools me it was shot in this super
compartmentalized way that even the
actors thought everything in the movie
was playing out simultaneously it's kind
of like everyone was the star of their
own little movie everyone was number one
on their own little call sheet and they
pretty much just had an entire week to
themselves to shoot the film the whole
movie was about them you know it's it's
funny but we all we all are the stars of
the movie this this movie was also born
at the height of the coveted pandemic
which added to the unique experience of
bringing this movie from the page to the
screen literally though from the page
this film was based on the book The
anti-social Network by Ben mesric it all
started in Canada where director Craig
Gillespie had a ton of downtime to just
surf the web when everything was locked
down during the pandemic I was living
this whole experience I was on the front
lines watching and he was so interested
in the story he found himself on every
Reddit board and devoured every news
article he could find that was covering
it until he received a phone call from
his friend Kevin who works at the studio
he has a deal with he said I think
there's a movie here which brings me to
our next point this was one of the
fastest ideas brought to Studios in
Hollywood history the process of finding
the film's idea getting ownership of the
intellectual property that created the
narrative and getting it greenlit by his
team was a process that took only three
days Craig Gillespie knew that everyone
in Hollywood would eat this story up
given the opportunity so oh the real
task in his mind was to get it going
before anyone else could and if we were
able to collect the right team we might
be able to beat everybody else it wasn't
a difficult task getting everyone
involved Rebecca Angelo and Lauren sugar
Blum were immediately captivated by The
Narrative and were brought on as both
executive producers and screenwriters he
said the words I think GameStop Ben
mesric movie and we were in pretty much
Shailene Woodley had a great time on the
set of this film though the irony of her
history and knowledge or really lack
thereof of finance and investing was not
lost on her I have taken classes on
investments I have listened to friends
for hours about investing she even
listened to nearly 30 hours of
investment YouTube videos trying to
retain an ounce of this information with
all of her efforts to get a handle on
essentially exactly what this movie is
about she just couldn't it's safe to say
that Shailene is not a method actor when
it comes to characters knowledgeable
about how day trading and hedge funds
work like my brain was not built for
mathematics or this world whatsoever
Paul Dano who plays the protagonist in
the film Keith Gill really honed in on
the transparency that he believes
represented his success he believes
Keith's honesty and straightforwardness
with the public made the whole
phenomenon happen he's real you see the
difference between these other guys and
him it was that realness he was trying
to embody when he was bringing his care
character to life especially at the time
in particular politicians were rubbing
the general public the wrong way so
Keith was like a breath of fresh air
they're politicians like he was being
totally real even in the in the
testimony I felt something the cast had
a lot of fun with when it came to this
movie was learning about everything that
was actually real a lot of the things on
screen you might think were falsified
for the drama like the whole pig
storyline but you'd actually be
surprised pig pepp pig that lived in
that house for about 10 years I think it
was until he got too big to be at the
mansion and they and they put it out on
a farm and gay Plotkin the hedge fund
guy Seth Rogen plays at actually has so
much money it's wild dude bought not
only one but two Mansions side by side
on the waterfront in Miami and tear down
one of them to build a tennis court for
his family I mean good for him but man
and the real Kevin Gill the one played
by Pete Davidson really did run a mile
fully nude during a lightning storm the
cast had a lot of real life to pull from
when bringing us this movie so who's
bummed out they didn't get in on this
GameStop Trend during the pandemic it's
clear by the amount of passionate
creators behind the film that this was
not only a cultural phenomenon but
something that continues to have a
lasting effect on our society and the
monetary value we place on things as a
whole what was your favorite part of
this story